mer monsieur le ministre l'ordre du jour
appelle la question orale de Monsieur
Christian Cambon à Monsieur le Ministre
chargé des transport de la mer et de la
pêche c'est Madame procacia en
remplacement de Monsieur Christian
Cambon qui va
s'exprimer bonjour monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues merci effectivement Christian
Cambon a été retenu pour un enterrement
et n'a pas PL venir mais la question que
je vous pose concernant Orli nous
concerne en tant qu'élu et parlementaire
du valdeemarne puisqu'elle pose sur un
dossier que vous maîtrisez et que vous
connaissez bien qui est le cadre de vie
des milliers de de riverins de cet
aéroport il a fait l'objet d'un
programme d'extension par Aéroport de
Paris qui est une société privée mais
dont l'état est actionnaire majoritaire
de 450 millions d'euros qui vise à
accroître les capacités d'Orly pour
accueillir 50 % de trafic supplémentaire
à cette fin 100000 m² de surface
additionnelle on sont en cours de
réalisation notamment une nouvelle
aérogard joignant les terminaux ouest et
sud ainsi qu'un satellite d'embarquement
dédié au gros porteurs une enquête
publique a bien été ouverte et s'est
déroulée jusqu'au 9 novembre 2013 mais
elle n'a concerné qu'une fraction du
programme de travaux et surtout n'a été
mise en œuvre que sur cinq communes
limitrophes pourtant ce sont près de 30
communes du valdeemarne ou de lesson euh
et parfois même de cénémarne qui sont
touchés par le plan de gêne sonore de
l'aéroport et qui ne figurait pas dans
le périmètre de cette enquête face à
l'augmentation du nombre de passagers
ADP prévoit de passer de 27 à 40
millions de passagers et sans qu'aucune
nouvelle plateforme ne soit prévue
ailleurs pour absorber la hausse du
trafic aérien les élus euh du
valdeemarne et certain nombre de
lessones c'est lève contre un
dépassement de l'objectif de
plafonnement de cet aéroport enclavé à
200000 mouvements il s'oppose également
à l'objectif annoncé qui est
d'accueillir les gros porteurs en nombre
ce qui aurait pour conséquence une
augmentation des demisan sonorees de la
pollution de l'air des contraintes
d'urbanisme ainsi que des risques
d'accident il est donc normal que les
riverins de toutes les communes
concernées puissent être consultés pour
avoir accès au documents techniques du
projet et donner leur avis euh je crois
savoir enfin Christian Cambon croit
savoir que le ministère s'est déjà
prononcé sur cette question lors d'une
audience accordée à l'association ville
et aéroport et vous vous seriez déclaré
favorable à un élargissement de la
consultation aux communes concernées je
vous demande de confirmer votre accord
pour élargir cette concertation sur ce
projet d'autant que depuis que Christian
Cambon a posé cette question je vois que
la commission d'enquête publique a rendu
un avis favorable à l'extension de
l'aéroport mais aussi suggérer une
enquête menée par la
CNDP merci madame procasscia monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice procassia je ne
reviens pas sur la description du du
projet vous l'avez fait qui est un
projet bien connu même si je tiens à
souligner qu'il l' éoné de continuer à
parler de de 40 millions de passagers et
pour la cible de trafic sur lequel a été
élaboré ce ce projet l'enjeu porté par
ADP est conformément à sa mission de
traiter convenablement la croissance
naturelle du
trafic c'est ce trafic qui est projeté à
32 millions de passagers comme indiqué
dans les documents de du dossier de
l'enquête publique je constate que c'est
un projet qui sucite des inquiétudes
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer les
élus vousmême vous en faites
porte-parole bien qu'ADP est déjà procéd
à une cinquantaine de présentations au
profit d'une centaine d'élus de
collectivité réven vous avez fait
référence à ma rencontre avec
l'association ville aéroport et je
confirme que suite à cette rencontre et
aux demandes que j'ai pu formuler auprès
d'ADP ADP a accédé à ma demande de
poursuivre ces démarche de présentation
auprès des communes concernées par le
plan de gêne sonore en envoyant d'ors et
déjà un courrier au maire de ces
différentes communes pour les inviter à
reprendre contact s'ils le souhaitent
l'objectif de ce projet de moderniser
l'outil aéroportuaire d'Orly afin de de
permettre de le mettre à niveau des
standards internationaux de qualité de
service pour les passagers et ce faisant
de renforcer le bénéfice
socio-économique des territoires
desservis il ne s'agit en aucune manière
je tiens à le réaffirmer avec force de
promouvoir un développement effrainé du
trafic au détriment des populations qui
serait touché par des nuisances
résultant des activités aériennes le
gouvernement d'ailleurs ne n'aurait
jamais apporté son soutien à un projet
quiait pour conséquence de revenir sur
des caractéristiques fondamentales
attachées à l'aéroport existant d'Orly
que sont par exemple et chacun y est
attaché le couvrefeu nocturne ou le
plafond de 250000 créneaux horaires par
an tous les riverins peuvent être
convaincus qu'il n'y aura pas de de
bradage de la part du gouvernement sur
ces deux points nous y sommes
extrêmement attentifs et je l'ai rappelé
aux élus que j'ai rencontré par ailleurs
ce projet ne porte pas en lui un
accroissement significatif du nombre de
mouvements par gros porteurs et il n'y a
pas de d'évolution majeure de ce type de
trafic ni même sur les destinations de
cet aéroport d'orli notons quand même
que l'utilisation de ces gros porteurs
est un sens va dans le sens
d'une d'une amélioration écologique
d'abord parce que il permet de optimisé
et par ailleurs il permet de d'util de
de d'avoir recours à des engins qui sont
aussi par l'évolution technologique
moins brouyant moins brouyant même que
un certain nombre qui sont aujourd'hui
des des moyens porteurs tel que nous les
connaissons al en NRE
euh nous devons nous assurer à ce que
les normes de sécurité quel que soit le
type d'avion soit respecté nous y sommes
là aussi extrêmement attentifs alors
j'ai reçu soutien des 13 maires des
communes membres de l'Association des
communes et communautés du Grand orlit
qui m'ont fait connaître leur adhésion
au projet pour autant je souhaite qu'il
y ait une concertation qui soit
optimisée ADP a répondu en ce sens et
par ailleurs je suis extrêmement
attentif aux préoccupations que sont
celles exprimées par la population et
donc par les élus merci Monsieur le
Ministre madame
procacia monsieur le ministre de ces
propos qui sont rassurant mais c'est
vrai par rapport au coût des avions par
rapport à la rentabilité à l'OPEX on a
rendu un un rapport sur l'avenir de
l'aviation civile qui montre bien que
les choses vont beaucoup évoluer et
c'est normal que dans un tissu urbain
aussi dense que celui de l'aéroport
d'Orly il y ait des inquiétudes des
inquiétudes des riverins et des rivrin
très étendus pour notre part la
modernisation de Orly qui est le plus
vieil aéroport en tout cas de la région
parisienne je sais pas d'ailleurs était
indispensable c'est vrai qu'il était
très mal pratique et que ces bâtiments
vont être plus opérationnels avec des
objectifs de tourisme d'affaires mais il
y a une inquiétude pour les gros
porteurs
euh je ne suis pas une technicienne de
l'aviation mais c'est vrai que le débat
est de dire est-ce qu'un gros porteur
même nouvelle génération n'est pas quand
même plus bruyant et on va pas augmenter
le nombre de nuisance en outre vous le
savez que l'arrêté du 13 mars 2013 a
abaissé les recett de la taxe la tnsa
sur les nuisances aériennes qui
finançait l'aide à l'incenirisation des
riverins donc une diminution du tarif
horaire et la loi de finan de 2014 les a
limité à 49 millions d'euros soit 6
millions et demi de moins qu'en 2012 euh
tout en élargissant par paradoxalement
la le périmètre de couverture donc
comment voulez-vous que c'est les
riverins que les élus ne soi pas inquiet
et se demande s'il n'y a pas une
contradiction entre l'affichage du
gouvernement qui nous dit soutenir les
projets d'Orly mais avec des contraintes
qui respectent les riverins et ces
mesures qui sont un peu en contradiction
en tout cas je me réjouis que cette
concertation puisse être étendue et que
comme la commission d'enquête a été
étonnée du nombre de remarques reçues et
d'inquiétudes qu'effectivement on aille
plus loin sur les inquiétudes des
riverins je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre merci Madame procaia l'ordre du
jour appelle la question orale de
Monsieur Jean-Marie bequel monsieur
ministre du Travail de l'Emploi de la
Formation Professionnelle et du dialogue
social Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE monsieur si
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre je souhaite attirer votre
attention sur la situation actuelle et
àenir des maisons de l'emploi et de la
formation